call the dragon
he makes a good good one step and push
using opposite hand you know there's
actually no nothing wrong with that one
so if you're talking to carl right now
it's less
that one actually you you created a
spectacular one but in a good way
[Music]
from where he punches the ball
i think it could have gone anywhere
and
in as well of the bar so i think that's
a
actually this is a great save and great
commentary as well
the appreciation from the fans i think
that makes it even even better one last
question it was roy the lap's throwing
was that hard to deal with the throw in
the famous throw-in the throwing as well
i because he knew exactly where he
throws it
but he couldn't know how far it goes
right because i think you could have
about 10 yards difference in the throws
even when he threw it the same way
depending on how sweet
you know this the throw was so you could
have the same throw coming towards the
middle spot but it could have gone even
past the second post so that was the
difficult part and it was low you know
it's like an arrow so you have you don't
really have a nice looping ball where
you can go and catch it it just actually
everybody can run onto it and i think at
times it was more dangerous than
than actually the the cross so okay it
was it was a great challenge i have to
say
call the dragon
[Music]
i think the one thing i have to give him
is that he made it look spectacular
[Laughter]
he makes a good good one step and push
using opposite hand you know there's
actually no nothing wrong with that one
so it's for the cameras but at least the
transition and the push
in the big goal actually is correct so
yeah okay so if you're talking to carl
right now it's less
that one actually you
you created a spectacular one but in a
good way
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
absolutely brilliant
i have to say this is the reason why the
dead should not be behind the goal in
the first place
you know what
my son plays in goal i'm never around
the god
well or if i am i just don't i just
don't say anything i just watch and i
don't say anything because i want him to
play the game not i'm not playing the
game he plays the game so he has to
figure it out himself so
i think we all we all been there
you know but as soon as you you want to
throw it and then you decide not to this
is exactly what happened so
i have to say i i haven't
managed to score and go
like that
but i had fun in situations with it as
well when the you know you stop and the
ball goes in the air and then you chase
it somewhere when you make a mistake
like that petter how do you pick
yourself up
you know in
i think is individual some people will
just dwell on the mistake and make
another five
which is obviously the danger when i
played in my mind the game was always
the game was always uh nil nil i didn't
follow score during the games i follow
my job
so i basically every second i just
concentrate on what i have to do in
order to finish the game
and to make the most saves and and to do
the best things i could so whether we
were three nil up or
three nil down it wouldn't make any
difference in the way i played
but obviously you know when you make it
when you when you score an ongoing like
that then obviously
the toughing it leaves
a bad taste really better is in your
mouth
so this this probably you know we can
we can probably stop here with this
quadruple or whatever safe
monster safe penalty rebound second
rebound third rebound i think that's i i
just love how his um his team
believed in him because you know these
guys were shooting about five times and
and you don't see a blue shirt there so
i would say
this is exactly the team who who has the
motor who who defends don't trust the
keeper
this is quite extraordinary i have to
say
i haven't seen anything like that first
i i don't know why the goalkeeper runs
to the corner flag
when the ball goes out of play and
nobody needs to go there
and when the game when the ball stayed
in play he was waving for a
i don't know for what a very hopeful
offside
i think it's that hopeful wave when you
wave and you go please help me out
come on find something left with it
you know i think
there is many many goalkeepers who have
a great shot
because you you practice kicking the
ball so many times in training are you
one of them well you kick because you
have to kick and you even even sometimes
when you make a pass you want to hit
players on the run in the space you need
to curve the ball
and you kick a lot of balls even not
with a
with like a long run
that's a great free kick i would shoot
free kicks and penalties just the the
one of the coaches that would let me
sometimes but then when you get you know
like a
top league you know i've never never
seen a
manager who would say oh you know what i
have 11 top players i just let michael
keep her shoot
and i have to say to be honest we had so
many great free kick takers in the teams
i was that there was no need for me to
shoot yes but i said i don't think
drogba would step down for you
i don't think they would let me anyway
well i think he's not the first in the
last goalkeeper who's ever done that i
think next time he will think twice
but you know as much as it looks as much
as he looks completely silly
and his reaction is quite silly you know
it can always happen one little awkward
bounce and and you put you know you
you take the eyes of the ball and
that's it the tragedy is done
but i i've done few i've i'm i made a
couple of those
i have to say i did one at swansea when
i
had about six ideas in one second
[Laughter]
then the ball
awkwardly bounced and then i instead of
kicking it i wanted to pass it and then
it hit my shin and
somebody tapped it in after so i can i
know i don't laugh at this one so much
because i've done it myself and i know
how badly you feel after that so
so in third place
i have this goalkeeper with the throw
out which end up in the goal
because it's so hard to do
and it never hit
you know to get it right that you mess
up with the throw and you actually end
up and throwing it in the net you know
it needs so many things to go to go
wrong that it actually happened so i
think you know i i take this one my
second
is
the goalkeeper who saves the penalty
here when they pay the purpose shirt and
all the
saves after because he was absolutely
brilliant in
making the choices and blocks and
and saves so that's my second
and then
there were so many
but this one
where
the goalkeeper runs towards the corner
flag and the ball stops there i have to
choose this one because it's very rare
it's really rare to see you know the the
situation like that and and
overall even the reaction after this
so
i will go with
with with with this one
[Music]
oh brave as a button you sicko
he's in the makings to be an absolute
beast what a goalie i love that